foreign
[Music]
foreign foreign
foreign
and today this Summit has made two
things absolutely clear the first is a
message for you and for the people of
Ukraine the EU will support you in every
way we can for as long as it takes we
are not intimidated and will not be
intimidated by the Kremlin because
Ukraine ndeu We Are Family
in my second message the future of
Ukraine is within the European Union the
Ukrainian people you have made a clear
choice for freedom for democracy and
Rule of flow and we in the EU we have
also made a clear decision your future
is with us in our common European Union
your destiny is our destiny and that's
why together with Ursula which is the
people where we are here today standing
by your side Mr President Vladimir this
again a moving moment because you are a
symbol of your people a reflection of
your people's courage and bravery
our support has been worked solely since
day one and it will continue
our over support amongst to nearly 60
billion euros from weapons to Military
Support from generators to Transformers
supporting your schools hospitals and
created infrastructure and we are
determined to help you win on the
battlefield
so far dim Europe is mobilized nearly 12
billion euros of Military Support
including little military support and we
are training an initial 30 000 Ukraine
soldiers this year the EU has also
secured 18 billion euros of microfinance
resistance for 2023 and also provide
some humanitarian and civil protection
assistance
millions of ukrainians have fledged the
war seeking safety and protection and
right to express our sincere gratitude
to all Europeans who have stepped up to
help these women children and families
with housing Education Health Care and
child care this is an emblem of our
European solidarity and it will continue
will continue to ramp up the pressure on
Russia to end the war
the EU has already adopted nine packages
of hard-hitting sanctions and we must do
more we will do more a tense package is
being designed to curb pressure through
a machine even further and these
extensions are working we can watch as
economy and the private it of critical
Technologies
the Kremlin
estimating war crimes in Ukraine and it
must be held accountable we support
investigations of the prosecutor of the
international criminal court
you and your trade continue to work
together to ensure full accountability
and this includes for the crime of
aggression through an appropriate
mechanism we support establishing an
international center for the prosecution
of the cryo Federation in Ukraine in the
area
in addition to accountability
only made sense that they should pay
Russia should pay to rebuild Ukraine and
we are committed to looking at ways of
using Frozen sets to be built what
Russia has destroyed
ladies and gentlemen
both Ukraine and the EU we share the
common goal of ending this war with
respect for Ukraine sovereignty and
territorial integrity and we therefore
support Ukraine's peace family
initiative and will actively work with
you with Ukraine on the 10 point peace
plan and we also that this idea of a
peace formula Summit to launch in order
to launch display
last June the 27 EU member State decided
to granted the status to Ukraine and
this was a major step
since then Ukraine has made considerable
efforts and progress especially on
judicial reforms and fighting corruption
we end towards Ukraine to continue
strengthen the rule of flow because it
benefits every Ukrainian citizen we will
be at your side every step of the way
in the meantime we continue working hand
in hand to unlock the full potential of
the association agreement and the deep
and comprehensive free trade agreement
we are also working to include Ukraine
in the European roaming area as soon as
possible this is another concrete step
in bringing Ukraine and the EU closer
together
the EU is received today the EU will be
with you and your people tomorrow and
for as long as it takes we will be right
by your side to rebuild a model question
Ukraine firmly entered on our common
European past because it can be no safe
and independent Europe without safe and
independent Ukraine Ukraine is the EU
the you if Ukraine let's make it happen
ing
thank you very much Mr President
thank you very much for hosting us here
at The Summit in Kiev
I often say that Ukraine is a true
inspiration for Europe
and this morning I had another reason to
say this I had the occasion to go with
prime minister Dennis schmidhal to a
post office at the maidan
and we met there with plenty of people
that came to exchange their old light
bulbs into LED modern light bulbs
it is part of our national and
international effort to reduce energy
consumption and it is part of the
donation of 50 million light bulbs LED
light bulbs that we have promised we
have already reached the figure of 35
million that can be delivered
um and it was amazing to see from the
moment on the message was out in the
first three days I was told 750
000 Ukrainian citizens came to the post
office that was the nearest exchange
their old light bulbs into modern LED
light bulbs to be part of those who save
energy and work for energy security
and I think this is symbolic
because after this short visit
on the maidan and the post office there
was the air raid and we had to go to the
shelter
and that shows the reality of every
single day the war reality that you are
experiencing here over and over again
and I must say
if there was needed a living proof
that Russia is suffering a massive
strategic failure but Ukraine is
withstanding and is building its path
towards the European Union well the fact
that we are here
for the 24th Summit
Ukraine European Union
amidst the world
but we are building discussing and
developing the future of Ukraine in the
European Union that is speaking more
than thousand words
and it's very down-to-earth what he has
done this is of course also the word
reality you have to act today on the
ground let's start with energy for
example as I said the 35 million LED
bulbs are one example if we take all of
them let's reach the figure of 50
million if we are able to distribute
them in the country
the saving equivalent of these 50
million LED light bulbs will be the
power production by one nuclear reactor
so so much can be done by simple means
just to help save energy and replace it
by better ones
we discussed of course much more how to
support energy security
at the moment being for example
generators are of utmost importance
to keep the electricity running so the
delivery of 5400 power generators is so
far agreed we repair infrastructure as
much as we can immediately and keep the
grid functioning
at the beginning of the war when we
connected our grids rapidly in record
speed to weeks it was Ukraine that
exported electricity to the European
union now it's the other way around
Ukraine needs electricity and yes we
will provide you with two gigawatt
electricity that you need with the help
of all the member states we are in one
energy Community already and that is the
solidarity that is the European uh phase
that we want to show
the same goes for fast recovery
helping now to repair the damages that
Putin's bombs are
doing to the energy infrastructure is
one part
but the repair of buildings of roads of
infrastructure over all schools hospital
is a daily job you have to do and
therefore it is so important that we
start with the fast recovery immediately
this is embedded in the larger process
of reconstruction
I am glad that we could announce that
the first one billion for fast recovery
will be provided we have now our
Secretariat between thief and the
European commission up and running so
the work can start immediately
um to make sure that the recovery is
immediately on the ground deliverable
but for the economy
the state functions have to be
maintained salaries have to be paid
social benefits the economy must run
so far the European Union has provided
in hindsight to Ukraine 50 billion
including the 18 billion that will be
the regular payments per month
um to the budget support of Ukraine
but we were also discussing how we can
increase the income the revenue for the
Ukrainian business and economy one point
is our security Lanes the security lanes
are a big success we strengthen them now
with another billion they are the
transport routes for all the goods from
Ukraine to the European Union in a fast
priority Lane 25 of Ukraine's GDP last
year has been transported through the
solidarity Lanes in value it's 20
billion that the revenues have provided
we will of course prolong the program of
tariff free access to the market so
Goods can come terrify from Ukraine to
the European Union as it was last year
it will be this year and Ukraine joining
European programs of course with waiving
the feasts that would have been to be
paid for these programs
yes we discussed also at this Summit how
to make Russia pay for the brutal
destruction it is causing we are
exploring with our partners the options
we have for that
the perpetrator must pay and must be
held accountable we are together in
collecting the evidence of the war
crimes we have the prosecutors know in
place we are discussing what kind of
institutional setup is necessary but for
us it's important that we have the
political will to make Russia pay for
what it did to Ukraine
Russia is already a Russia society and
economy is already paying a hard price
because of the sanctions that we imposed
the 10th package is on its way we have
the AIM to have it in place by the 24th
of February it has a volume of round
about 10 billion euros it's a massive
package again
the plan is to focus once more
on technology
that can and should not be used by
Russia's War Machine in other words we
look deeper into components that were
found for example in drones to make sure
that there's zero availability for
Russia of these Technologies or the
drones production for example in Iran
that we are following up closely
we will as a third element Focus
intensively on cutting circumvention
this is a topic so here the 10th package
will also have proposals to fight
circumvention last but certainly not
least
we focus of course on Ukraine's
accession path
your determination to forge ahead is
impressive
you're taking important steps with all
the reforms forward to meet the
recommendations
and we should not forget you are doing
this while you are fighting against an
aggressor
we will continue to support you on every
single step we discussed the details
besides reforms it is important to have
a good track record on implementation I
know you're working hard on that too and
rest assured
that your progress will be reflected in
our important enlargement report that is
due in Autumn for the member states
listening to you development Mr
President
I'm confident that you will keep up the
good Pace because you know what is good
for your country
and these reforms will anchor Ukraine in
our families of free and liberal
democracy Slava Ukrainian